sometimes it's hard to tell the
difference between easter eggs and clues
that video games share a universe
just so happens that sometimes they're
both let's take a closer look at some
video game universes with startling
connections
the uncharted and the last of us series
are two of playstation's biggest and
best first party exclusives
but did you know that one is actually a
sequel to the other
well kind of at least in uncharted 3
there's a newspaper with a headline
reading
scientists are still struggling to
understand the deadly fungus
an intentional reference to the last of
us at the time of uncharted 3's release
however
the last of us had yet to be formally
announced and that newspaper wasn't
actually supposed to remain in the game
naughty dog's neil druckerman candidly
told kotaku
we just completely forgot about it we
screwed up fortunately for them they
ended up getting away with it
without spoiling their then upcoming
announcement
what took you so long what took you so
long what takes so long
japanese video game designer hideo
kojima likes to fill his games with
easter eggs
and that's why his graphic adventure
game police notes offers plenty of clues
that it shares a universe with snatcher
and metal gear solid
police north has tons of snatcher
references in addition to a few direct
cameos from the cyberpunk adventure game
there's a snatcher calendar in june
ishida's office and victor juergens uses
the same brand of sunscreen
found in both games there's also a
snatcher target in the police station's
shooting range
that plays a remix version of the game's
pressure of tension song
when it's hit in metal gear solid you
can find two promotional posters for
police north in the nuclear warhead
storage building with a third popping up
in metal gear solid 2 sons of liberty
dreben 893 drinks a soda called nak
which is named after the addictive drug
in police north and there's even a bar
named after solid snake in police nords
old la
and that's just scratching the surface
of the cosmic clues happy hunting
the red faction series from volition and
thq tells the story of the titular
faction's resistance against the
oppressive reign of the nefarious altar
corporation
set amidst a sci-fi future of dystopian
proportions
meanwhile the saints rose series from
volition and thq
along with later day publisher deep
silver chronicles the story of the third
street saints
a street gang turned the global crime
organization who faced rival criminals
and corrupt law enforcement
drawing their ongoing slapstick quest
for domination while the first game in
the series was a relatively
straightforward gta clone
later entities well they got a little
wild you can't
kill me my people will
avenge my death not with a bed but with
a whimper
as luck and the cheeky developers of
volition would have it
the events of the red faction series
actually take place in the future of the
saints row universe and the nefarious
altor corporation
is the link the old tour corporation has
been using a secret r d
lab to conduct unethical experiments on
the citizens of stillwater
in case you missed it the episodic
expansion packs altar exposed
and corporate warfare for saints row 2
are probably the most overt references
to red factions big bad adversaries
in the saints series the first of these
two dlc packs lays the groundwork for
exposing the megacorps cd operations
while the second installment offers
players a chance to quote
put a permanent end to altor's
corruption head on the results one of
the craziest canonical crossovers in
video game history
remedy entertainment's connected
universe is more intricate than many
fans realize
remedy's 2010 game alan wake is a
bizarre trip through alternate
dimensions
as the title character searches for his
missing wife he begins to see elements
of a story he wrote coming to life the
endings of alan wake and its followers
left its heroes fate and clear
which has tormented fans for years but
did you know references to mr wake have
shown up in remedy's newer titles
quantum break released in 2016 features
several callbacks to alan wake
for instance a chalkboard in the game
seems to describe events from alan wake
not only that another easter egg
revealed live-action footage of alan
wake himself
then came 2019's control through
documents discovered drawing
control players learn that the game's
federal bureau of control
investigated the events of alan wake but
unfortunately didn't find much
footage of allen can also be found in a
hidden area of the game
finally control's awe expansion brought
bureau director jess faden into conflict
with emile hartmann
a mad psychologist with ties to allen
and alice wake
the malaysia-inspired island of penal is
the setting of just cause 2
the 2010 open world action adventure
game from avalanche studios and idols
interactive
it tells the continuing story of chaotic
hero rico rodriguez
and his battle against some of the
world's craziest militant dictators
interestingly enough penal also makes a
subtle appearance on sleeping dogs the
hong kong-based action adventure from
united front games
and idos parent publisher square enix
one easter egg from sleeping dogs
definitively places these two games in
the same universe
if your timing and radio station are
correct you'll hear a fun little
advertisement that shouts out
a familiar setting of just cause 2. for
a relaxing getaway
visit the island of penal an exotic
location where beauty
and luxury are an everyday pleasure
french video game publisher ubisoft made
its reputation by developing some of the
most immersive open world games on the
market
games that emphasize exploration and
branching narratives over linear
storytelling
and guided adventures it's no surprise
then that ubisoft would decide to set a
few of their fan favorite franchises in
a shared universe but the clues aren't
always upfront
fortunately for us the modern day
sequences of assassin's creed 4 black
flag
offer some clarity set in the offices of
a video game development studio known as
abstergo entertainment
a not so subtle front from stair go
industries aka the templar order
the assassins rival faction these
sequences provide several distinct
references
to ubisoft's watchdogs and far cry 3.
for instance the security system's
presentation offers a blatant reference
to the primary city-wide hacking
mechanic
of watchdogs nowhere is our expertise
more apparent than in our flagship
product
ctos a groundbreaking proprietary
security software operating system
meanwhile the abstergo entertainment
database entry for us a lot
obliquely suggests that far cry 3 the
video game itself
could actually be yet another virtual
construct of the animus
did i ever tell you the definition
of insanity the science fiction stylings
of nia automata from platinum games and
publisher square enix
seemed like a far cry from the medieval
fantasy of drakengard from caviar inc
and macrospace but these two action rpgs
are separated by a lengthy span of
sequels
and studio changeovers so they actually
exist squarely in the same universe
the description of nia automata on the
game's official website
tells us that story takes place in the
distant future
that future is in fact the far-flung
time period following the events of
drakengard
which chronicles the dark fantasy story
of the deposed prince khaim
and his efforts to stop the malevolent
watchers from destroying the world
game scholars understand the e ending of
drakengard in which kyme and his dragon
power angelus travel across a
dimensional boundary to fight the queen
grotesquery in modern-day tokyo
to be the canonical ending that leads
into the 2010 hack and slash rpg
near which is itself a direct forerunner
of nia automata
don't worry if you're confused you're
not the only one in neo-automata
quote mankind has driven from earth and
takes refuge on the moon
now with the full history laid out
before us we finally understand that
particular earth to be the alternate
history earth of drakengard
known as midgard with ample evidence of
a ufo conspiracy that interlinks the
background narratives of grand theft
auto 5 and red dead redemption 2
it's safe to say that rockstar games is
no stranger to shared game worlds
but did you know that manhunt from
rockstar north was also set in the gta
universe
a variety of evidence suggests that it
is notably the very location of the
game's controversial narrative
manhunt takes place within the fictional
setting of carson city
a ruthless lampoon of america's rust
belt where street gangs rule the night
gta fans who paid enough attention will
probably recognize casa city
from one of its many subtle appearances
in the series it's been mentioned at
least once in every grand theft auto
release since gta 3
including the story spin-offs developed
for handheld consoles
in nearby carcer city
a good day for law order as police chief
gary shaver was cleared of corruption
charges
and if there was any doubt james olkash
manhunt sociopathic protagonist appears
unwanted posters within the grand theft
auto universe
most notably in locations like the
police department in san andreas
crime might not pay but in rockstar's
shared worlds it'll definitely make you
famous
with its focus on a single player
campaign battlefield bad company from
dice was a bit of a departure from the
tried and true formula
of the fan favorite fps franchise in
2008 but the game's humorous narrative
along with its introduction of highly
destructible environments
made it a smash hit gamespark called it
quote quite simply one of the most fun
shooters released that year
dice was also responsible for mirror's
edge catalyst the 2016 sequel of their
unique sci-fi action platformer
also from 2008 catalyst expanded the
story and gameplay of the original
and took a few narrative liberties in
his effort to round out the law behind
faith connors and her death-defying run
through the city
dice looked into their previous titles
to establish a real world element for
the dystopian future of mira's edge by
replacing the boys from bad company
directly into the expanded narrative of
catalysts via audio files
yeah we're on first name basis
it's a bromance you know both
corporations legendary
first-person shooter half-life changed
the video game industry forever when it
hits personal computers in 1998
it tells a heart-pounding story of
theoretical physicists gordon freeman
and his dimension shattering discoveries
at the black mesa research facility
and curiously enough a black mesa would
prove to be part of the game's
connective tissue to another valve title
portal the award-winning 3d puzzle
platformer released in 2007.
portal takes players on a wild ride
through the aperture science
laboratories
as they try to unravel the enigmas of
the artificial intelligence known as
glados
and learn for themselves that the cake
is alive astute gamers will recognize
the bleed clues in glados's dialogue
that reference the events of half-life
along with a tongue-in-cheek powerpoint
presentation
furthermore aperture founder cave
johnson mentions his black mesa rivals
by name multiple times in portal 2.
whether or not industrial espionage is
healthy for business it's certainly made
for one sweet spin-off
hey johnson new owner and ceo of black
mesa that's right you've been bought
first order of business we're renaming
you under the aputure brand
due in 2022 the callisto protocol is a
survival horror game
set in the furthest reaches of outer
space the game places players in the
shoes of a prisoner in black iron a
prison located on jupiter's moon
callisto
when aliens attack the facility it's up
to the prisoner to fight the invasion
and get out alive developed by striking
distance and directed by dead space
co-creator glenn scofield
the terrifying looking game seems like a
far cry from the setting of player
unknown's battlegrounds
however as a striking distance rep
confirmed for ign
the two games are actually linked by a
shared universe in an interview with
gamesradar scofield said that although a
few hundred years and plenty of space
separates pubg
and the callisto protocol hardcore fans
would most likely be able to pick up on
the references to the wider pubg
universe throughout the game
scofield explained we're helping pubg
core right now as a team of writers
working on the law for pubg and its
universe it's not going to be really
deep but there will be little
connections here and there
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one